welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace Helbig the
first again as always a very exciting
episode we have Harvey Gillen again I he
told me how to pronounce his name a lot
and I just I'm just bad at it but what
he's great at is being a human being he
is hilarious sweet funny fashionable
hard-working you're gonna fall in love
with him if you don't already know him
he is hilarious on what we do in the
shadows on FX he's been actually
hustling and making money since he was
like six years old and he's just the
most gracious wonderful human being so
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
Harvey all right it's happening Harvey
I'm so excited that you're here
thanks for having me of course you were
killing it right now oh yeah I am thank
you I guess I am yeah yeah
killing it yeah yeah what we're doing
the shadows is so fun I love it it's
hilarious and I was so excited when I
heard that you were gonna be in it also
I've been doing like a little bit of
research you got the audition because
you went to a cheese party I went to
wine and cheese night so I got a call
from my friend Mimi my cause shout to
Mimi
hey that she was in town for a couple
days and she was like hey I'm at my
brother's house almost feel as you
should come over have wine in cheese and
I was at home my pajamas literally
watching what was next on cue like for
you know I'm lying to watch and the
thing that was on cue actually to watch
that everyone recommend it and I hadn't
seen it and I hate myself for it was
what we do the shadows and that was on
your kids in the couch and I decided to
not watch it I got away and cheese night
and I just meet her like you know
friends from school and her brothers
there her husband and we're just having
you know why didn't she's in nothing big
and the next day I get a text from an
unknown number and it's aw hey you were
so [ __ ] funny okay like I said yes
like you know thanks so much was
hangouts like no I think you should she
for my fiance's news show I was like not
doing those kind of films anymore
she was like no what are you talking
about like nothing you just Chuck you
out and she's like no serious you should
audition because this was about January
8th last year and the time we just came
back from the holiday break
and they've been auditioning since
September the phone yes I was like what
and she was like yeah they're gonna cast
this world this week and I got the
script now edition and I called and I
was like who's auditioning this and it's
Allison Jones so if you know Allison
Jones she's cast everything understand
like the office bridesmaids Fresh Prince
of bel-air golden girl like the list
goes on so I was like I want to go meet
her and I read the script and the
character was 20 years older than I was
and I was like oh no I'm too young for
the role I was like um no I should think
I could do it okay well let's go in and
I did it there's one of the things as an
actor when you like do something you
walk away and I just don't know what I
did
oh yeah you black out and like that and
I just like I don't know what I did and
like my manager and agent were like what
did you do know like I don't know okay
like four hours later they had called
and said that they showed to FX taiko
Jemaine Scott like everyone everyone
just said unanimously he said I would go
test for it the same day same day well I
was like you know and so you're gonna go
test Freight oh my god I went test for
that's a cool I'll be the wild-card like
the young version of this character and
you know you test for stuff all the time
and they're like you don't know - the
other day yeah and then sounds like okay
I'm just gonna do it my way and I didn't
know when it was gonna be or when the
test was happening and I just kept
waiting and waiting that kept getting
this phone call from like a 16 digit
number oh my God give me a sign when is
the test and the phone would ring I
ignore it because I don't know anybody
yeah ventually I was like give me a sign
the phone kept ringing was like is it
and I picked up in as a hi this hobby
and I was like yeah hey it's talking
Jemaine you know distress and the other
me and I was like what no I'm testing
for it like no you're the mate I'll see
ya what I never tested for it
really I can Jeannine calls me directly
and they're like yeah you got it that's
incredible that crazy that's so nuts
yeah also they didn't leave a message no
I always pick up your phone and I always
go to wine and cheese night yeah it's
gonna say that um are two of the most
adult pieces of advice ever
that's very much almost adult thing I've
ever said she's a and then I answered my
phone yeah
I am nuts how has it been has it been a
whirlwind
yeah it's and crazy so we wrap the the
series like two days before Christmas
okay so that wasn't that long ago but it
felt like it was just yesterday and we
should in Toronto and it was just you
know we get to improvise and like she's
gonna say how much does it stick to a
script are you mean we have a script but
we don't really like you know we're not
sticklers for like every word has to be
perfect because we already have amazing
writers so it's not like you know it's
like we're we have to make this better
it's already good like when we get the
script we have amazing writers like
Stephanie Robinson
you know who's from Atlanta like she's
amazing I'm just talking her today and
it's just we just get the Liberty to
make it like you know more of the
character like it's like now how would
you do that as gear you know that's so
nice yeah cuz you're usually on set and
then maybe changed one word like that's
not what that says right the cat went
outside not the cat left you know yeah
and you want to like respect the writers
that you don't want to be able to play
which is so nice to be able to do I
always said they're like find a job that
I could do that that would be the dream
job and I found it that's all you guys
have already been greenlit for season 2
- that's so exciting in the fall that's
so cool
how is the energy onset it seems like
everyone's just having a blast it's like
playing hot potato with pros like
they're just the potato never falls down
like you're just like hot potato hoppity
hoppity it's like 16 hours later hot
potato like you can keep going forever
like this cast is amazing we had one
scene that should have been about two to
three minutes long because it wasn't how
much dialogue was like two pages and we
went for 26 minutes 26 minutes and and
no one said cut because everything was
great but we didn't know that was gonna
be able to you know come on please I
have so much respect for editors because
like you have like the worst job because
there's so much footage just so much and
I don't even know we're gonna do with
that extra fridge don't even know we're
gonna pro like it it's a special you
know blu-ray or whatever I don't know
where it's in a live like it's just out
there in the universe and that beautiful
beautiful whole
fine house the feedback bin I think it's
hilarious and you're fantastic in it
it's been great people have like really
just you know taking on to the
characters and latched on to like you
know what they love like they love the
quirkiness of the characters they love
will
you know Guillermo hashtag team
Guillermo and floating around because I
feel that we're all Guillermo world yeah
he's the only human in the house and
he's just endearing where he's all of us
have we've all been out for you know a
job that we want a relationship and we
think we're being seen a certain way
it's like this is definitely a
relationship or I'm definitely eating
this promotion and it's like know what
who are you yeah yeah overlooked for
something and I think everyone can
relate to that so everyone's like I feel
freaky everyone's like you feel freaky
yet mo because you argue did you get to
be on set with Tilda Swinton I did not
she was talking to me and you know
what's weird about having such a cool
episode like that way of spoiler have
you seen this episode we have such great
cameos oh it's I was like this is nuts
this is crazy there's no way we could
have made everyone schedule work on the
same day let you know it's just not
gonna happen and so what they were smart
they they shot different actors in
different parts I think she's shot in
the UK and someone else shot in LA and
we shot her on it like everyone was
everywhere but it's so weird cuz when
you're acting they're not in front of
you but you know that's her because that
scene her and how she played and she's
oh like this this and you're just like
wow she's like she was looking at me I
wasn't excuse me I just imagined that
she didn't get any hair and makeup for
that scenes great and then Danny Trejo
is in it as well yeah and I actually
shot with Danny Hashanah filmed a couple
years ago and so it's funny to be in a
scene where we're together again but
we're not know you been how long have
you been officially like auditioning out
here and doing this whole last probably
10 years 10 years yeah like out of high
school like I went to school and then I
went to a show in Japan
I did a musical in Japan well here's a
cartoon months it was a package deal you
did three shows in 13 months she did
like Blues Brothers and susta me Street
Live and wicked how was that it was
different because when I showed up to
sad or when we were rehearsing with the
director I got the script she knows in
Japanese oh wow and as like oh I'm sorry
this is Japanese that's fine like go
ahead like no the line shows and oh my
god we open in two weeks
aha and so I had to learn the script
Japanese in the songs Japanese did not
know that going in I literally I just
got so excited I booked a role I was
like well it's an American show and so
yeah America shall go to Japan and like
do it in English Harvey think so I
wasn't I got there but I learned
Japanese really quick I mean I guess you
had to Jesus so much yeah this day I
can't hear the wizard song wicked
without singing in Japanese calming
about that have you because of this
learned any like colloquial Japanese at
all yeah I had to learn like to get by
you know you surprised how quickly learn
when you're trying go to the store and
ask for milk and you look you know
really crazy going and you'd be
surprised how quickly you learn when
everyone around he speaks it and you
don't write you really do you know like
it's like you have to it's because I
think we become lazy you know it's like
why try wagging you know English yeah
yeah you're going to like Paris and like
was it somebody who was like not trying
at all and they went to ask for the
bathroom excuse was the bathroom like
they don't make an effort but if I gonna
kiss kit and I try to know you're trying
it's you know show that you're making an
effort you know like this like idea of
that going everywhere but like everyone
learned my language right so you were
there for 13 months yeah doing these
shows and then did you come straight
back from there I came straight back and
I moved to Brooklyn
I'm Broadway shut up and I was doing
like 5:00 a.m. cattle calls yeah I was
like why am I not getting the lead role
for Annie I lived in New York and we go
to commercial auditions I can't sing or
dance and in the same auditioning spaces
where the cattle calls for these
musicals and you'd go around the block
yeah and it'd be like you could guess
the musical by how everyone is dressed
it's like all these men dressed up like
you know 20s businessmen it's like how
to succeed in business and it was and
you could tell like who was there for
the Apple commercial I have like such
respect for musical theater performers
and stage performers because yeah it's I
feel like it's I mean LA and Hollywood
stuff you know but it's like imagine
doing eight shows a week I can't say
it's insane and so on TV well that's
what made me you know growing up in LA I
wanted to be a thespian I'm gonna be a
real actor not to TV actor or film
because those aren't real actors realist
stage actors and I went to school for
the whole thing I went for you know -
experience scholarship which is fear an
actor and then I realized I wasn't happy
I wasn't like having fun with it and
then I found musical theater I was like
I can do but it's still staged and then
I just realized you unless you're
perfect for a role and your name it's
really hard to break into it yeah and
you can only do the chorus so long
because you know I've always been short
and stout like they're not gonna go that
guy is boy dance which I can you know
but they don't assume that so I was
having a really hard time when I was
living New York and eventually like what
am i doing my agent back and legs like
there's a show show audition form was
like television I don't think so I don't
think so they're paying this much a week
you know I've always said television is
not that it's the same thing it's like
the Broadway of TV I'm gonna give it a
go and I had to stand for it I booked it
and what I made in a week you couldn't
make it a month you know what I mean so
I was like oh my gosh I can pay for
writing you know like I'm actually you
know I'm a place to live and then I just
transferred over to be like okay I'll do
if it comes up all edition and I kept on
the scene and I got like a commercial
and I
getting something I kept a small part
here in a two-line there and a
guest-star eventually leading to like my
first series regular yeah which was huge
by Savannah Julia Whitney Holtzman
Winnie Holzman who wrote the script -
wicked oh cool
so it was kind like full circle like I
am a new musical Winnie Holzman yeah but
it was perfect for mean it was such a
great platform to start off with it yeah
it got to play a really interesting
character and got some great feedback
and has a great platform cool how is
auditioning now versus the beginning
different for you you know is when I
first started it was you go to auditions
because you just you want the role but I
would go in for a lot of like fat guy
number two
oh yeah and fatty fatty 2x4 yeah and the
work that would always be in a
description when I was like guys be
clever about like it's like now it now I
think it's the same breakdown but it's
worded differently okay right so it's
like guy next door and then I remember
like auditions in the break down where
do you have a character named really
just be like big guy must be funny but
must be fat fat don't fit the facts you
know and I was just like jeez I get it
but it was a I think it's changed in
that way but I think we're going in the
right direction we're just changing and
giving people opportunity people of
color people sighs you know the
opportunity to be leads on shows yeah I
saw I was looking at your Twitter and I
saw the article where you were quoted
being like I never saw anyone like me on
TV yeah I do and I became that bit [ __ ]
I saw no one who looked like me I became
that [ __ ]
I remember watching Annie when I was six
years old and I was blown away that was
first time I saw a musical and I was
like mom I want to be that yeah I want
to be an orphan she looked at me he's
like Kay and I was like an orphan and
she was like oh no so knock though it is
and I was like you're lucky mom she's
like no one I thought is and you know
that's that's for rich kids she told me
Oh
like rich you have to be rich to play
poor on TV it's like yep that's
Hollywood doesn't make sense to me is
like those kids are trained they have
acting coaches and they have you know
voice and production and speech and all
this and I was like oh can I do that
no she's a where the [ __ ] are we gonna
get money for that she like single mom
like you know like is this like we're
waiting for the moment that's like well
okay I'll figure it out I'm six years
old I mean eventually find out that the
YMCA is doing like a improv class for
kids in the summer and I tell him I'm a
mom it's only told he says can I have
that's like jingle and I think like
where the [ __ ] are we gonna get money
feels like no and I'll give I get the
money can I do it
she doesn't become if you can get the
money you can do whatever you want and I
was like that was a first lesson
remember at 6:00 or less ain't wow if
you can find your own way
yeah no one can stop you and I will I'm
six years old what the [ __ ] am i doing
literally we're rocking home from school
one day and this guy who's homeless was
going through the trash cans like what
is he doing mom he's like Oh Levine it
was about this he sells the cans so you
make money off of bottles and cans and
she's like yeah I ran to her closet got
a wire hanger unhooked it and use it as
a hook to go to trash cans it was smelly
and disgusting it took me two weeks to
earn the six dollars in like 25 cents do
we have enough and I had to work another
two weeks selling after school getting
all the cans I went to parties and
quinceaneras I would pretend I was in
the party I took the class it was an
hour and a half the kids like
six-year-old so like eight or nine year
old kids together we didn't do anything
special we were walked around pertained
to be a lion now you're a tiger yeah it
was improv like wow this is magical and
after I was done with an hour and a
class I remember thinking I want to do
this it wasn't it was a month long
process to get that one hour and a half
oh yeah and then I thought yeah cuz no
one's ever gonna give you anything you
have to go out and get it
wow what an inspiring little kids yeah
that's it so that was me at six and kept
doing I worked at a swap me when I was
seven sold chocolates sorted or when I
was eight Wow I've been working since I
was six not professionally you
understand hard work absolutely any way
around immigrant you know parents they
do how how much do you tell your family
about the parts that you play like do
they are they do they know all about it
mom anything I do that has to do
anything in Spanish she loves okay like
I I won a GLAAD award you know for for
raising hope and I was like mama what a
GLAAD award you know she's like okay
when like she's like that's nice but I'm
the I was the spokesperson for MetroPCS
in Spanish like years ago for like a
couple years and she that was the Oscar
like when friend's car is me holy
MetroPCS and then she gets mad cuz I
don't do it but that's to her I've
already like hit like yeah man like
accolade that's so sweet
have you brought her to any like
red-carpet events or anything yeah I
bribed a couple of things like it's my
mom doesn't get blown away by let you
know she'll be next to like Tom Cruise
and should be like unison she's not like
slowly but if you like it's because it's
to her that's not her world you know but
if it's like a Mexican actress or Latin
American actor like oh god that's them
you know like the girl from that reality
show and I was like isn't that like Real
Housewives in Mexico well you and your
mom and I should hang out that's really
sweet also it's kind of grounding to
have that kind of energy at those events
because I always get very overwhelmed
you know situation I always bring like
my family with me they're hanging out
with me tonight like they could be
around celebs they still like you know
yeah to them they're like whatever
that's so sweet
okay what's been what was like the
hardest scene to shoot on Sep for well I
don't even know it was hard for me I
mean it was a little bit but I feel bad
for the vampires cuz when they're flying
yeah we just seen outside and it's
winter and it's Toronto and so I think
one day was like negative 10 it was
Thanksgiving weekend we're shooting over
Thanksgiving holiday and we've just seen
cave on went up and when he came down
before he went up he was just like you
know sniffling cuz it's really freezing
cold and I was like wow this is really
really cold and it gets colder as you go
yeah and so he went up like probably
like 10 floors of a building kind of
flew and then when he came down
he literally just had frozen like snot I
was like and then we just kept rolling
in his oh lucky and I was like master
I'll get that for you no and he didn't
feel it because he was so numb he was
just you were numb and so I feel bad for
them a lot they had scenes where they're
outside a window during the LARPing yeah
yeah I was spying on the kids they might
use as meals they're outside I started
like a gush of wind came and they're on
you know cranes and like hanging on
strings and they just started hitting
the building and they were just like
into each other it was just I was
watching and laughing yeah but it was I
think the weather was just like the only
part yeah the hardest part well I saw on
your Instagram the videos of you flying
for the first time it's all because I
was looking forward to fly the whole
season and I'm supposed to fly in the
fur and a second episode of the season
so I shot the pilot in the second
episode and the first scene I shot for a
second episode in Toronto was it came on
it was a second before I flew and the
last scene I shot three months later is
me flying that I struggle at 20 20
second scene
within three months of each other that's
like putting his hand out me grabbing it
and the next shot us flying together so
fine I don't mind it even the bruises it
looks very fun it also makes you guys
look like badasses yeah yeah I like that
actress if I like though that you know
badass like flying action stuff oh
that's cool okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I want to
ask about haters back off I would have
here worst auditioning stories all of it
okay we'll be right back with more not
too deep
[Music]
too deep this episode of Matthew deepers
brought to you by better help if there's
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors or specialize in
such issues as depression anxiety
relationships trauma anger family
conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment and get help
at your own time and own pace and
anything you share is confidential and
it's so convenient you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions as well
as chat and text with your therapist and
if for some reason you're not happy with
your counselor you can request a new one
at anytime for no additional charge and
best of all it's very affordable and not
too deep with grace helbig listeners
will get ten two percent off your first
month with the discount code grace so
why not get started today go to better
help calm slash grace then simply fill
out a questionnaire to help them assess
your needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you'll love that's better
help.com slash grace discount code grace
bill gets what's what's that going on
with the finale I mean we're recording
this before the finale officially comes
out but by the time this comes out the
finale will be so in the finale we do
well I do some blood work for everyone
ancestry okay and that's the same but we
find out that people's blood is from a
long lineage of different things like
for example Kay Vaughn's blood comes
from a very famous vampire and my blood
comes from we enough very famous vampire
hunter oh yeah
so if you can guess guess the name
members you can guess name vampire
hunter yeah killer vampire killer
I don't why am i blanking anyone anyone
anyone vampire killer vampire who's
Nosferatu right that's vampire who's a
vampire killer van Helsing
yeah that's right so am i I'm an
offspring event hell's haha that's gonna
be so fun yeah so now I know what I'm
drawn to vampires so much it's I think I
want to be one but is it because I meant
to because we watch the season I've
accidentally killed two vampires so far
mm-hmm the Baron and then one of the
cards that's right accident but really
good at it like yeah really enough I
killed him easily
yeah the killing the Baron was one of
the most hilarious yeah also that suit
is it a suit that he's wearing
yeah it's literally like he is it's
terrifying body thing like it's full
like he's amazing like we just saw him
couple weeks or last week actually for
fic for your consideration
so if you're an Emmy voter yeah he's
he's really great he takes hours just to
get into that oh it looks so insane
Doug Jones it's so creepy yeah do you
recognize him he's been on everything I
the creature in the shape of water oh
okay
he is Billy and hocus-pocus Ramona his
mouth is zipped oh yeah that's it open
and mouths come out that's him so he's
done all day oh he's a star trick now
yeah he's had stuff put all over his
body all the time that's what he's made
a career out of he's like I always would
have been well he there's one moment
that and I was a little high I'll admit
that he when he first comes out and he
notices the cameras like the documentary
crew for the first time and he looks and
right down the lens of the camera yeah I
was horrified I was like laughing but I
was like this is the scariest thing I've
ever seen I don't know so it's like yeah
very intense I was like I could not be
on this set like I wouldn't be able to
act next to this I would be actually
scared yeah it's a really fun you come
and visit the set in Toronto it's really
fun I would love to yeah look very
Victorian like the home is really
old-fashioned 'ok you're walking through
the setting all the details like the set
decorators and everyone have done an
amazing job it looks they don't mean
anything untouched like even the paper
that you touch those books from like
1690 it was a books that we have in
actual life there we'll never really
like you know
yeah then show you inside but it doesn't
matter like the actual book is so cold
it's so cool well you shot another sir
up in Canada right haters back off yeah
I would coulis with Colleen how did you
guys meet each other Cooley and I went
to school next to each other so well
that was three musical-theater shoes do
musical theater specific and I was doing
at citris right next door she also dated
a really good friend of mine in college
okay David Lamoureux uh-huh and that's
how we met I went to see her show
because David invited me he was like hey
just kiss my girlfriend I think it was
like Seussical the musical or something
okay and I went to see it I met her and
we just hit it off and we just stay in
touch and eventually they broke up with
their friends and we stayed friends and
it was just like this energy that we
have together then you get together and
just make stupid videos I well that's
how I watched her all of her like
instagrams stories and snapchats and
stuff when she was up in Vancouver there
we go shot yeah yeah shooting this and
you were in it and yet that was the
first time I got introduced to I was
like this boy is the most hilarious I've
ever seen this boy and then I didn't
realize that you were actually shooting
you're the fish store manager yeah yeah
I didn't know you're actually shooting
it I was like that's so cool that was
all her idea to because they wanted a
cast out of Vancouver as a local okay
and she brought me up to the cast are
like no we have to cast that role out of
Vancouver not gonna fly anyone over and
she really wanted me to do it and she's
I wrote it for you and she I was like
well you know if it works out it works
out yeah we always like with my friends
you know want to work together but it's
never like oh he didn't put me in your
show yeah yeah and so when she said you
don't have an idea
can you come to the table read and just
do the table read and I was like you
know yeah of course like yeah just do
the table read and I went to the table
read and I do it and the caster's I got
he's great he's gotta do it like oh do
you want to do it yeah if you want you
know yeah she's so clever and smart and
that's how I got the part is that had to
go in and show them that like no one
else could do the part she wrote it for
me and and once I did it they're like
yeah he's that and they I came back like
you know episodes later that's awesome
how was shooting that that was great
yeah I mean that was clean is very
efficient she knows what she wants and
she gets it done and and doing it with a
smile you know to find out sometimes
when you work and people get stressed
out and I think was Tina Fey who wrote
in her book like you never want to walk
down the hall at 4:00 a.m. across
someone that you don't want to be
working with yeah
so she surrounds herself who you know
are upbeat and cheerful and love what
they do this is great you know and she
did that from a character she developed
you know on YouTube it's like I'm always
like such a role model you know it's
like unbelievable she's a baby now and
she's still like going stronger than
she's gonna be touring again you're like
it's I'm like what am i I'm just
watching reality TV okay also the filth
what is this the fill series is actually
seriously just premiered and inside out
in Toronto okay this past weekend it's
the biggest LGBTQ Film Festival in the
world that's awesome and its
longest-running one so it's been running
for a really long time so we premiered
our series I'm a producer on the nimac
kilo cameo could I really love the story
it's directed by my writing partner
Jamie Holt okay who's an amazing
director and we need more female
directors and while we say that so she
directed this and I produced it we're
super proud of it it's about two queer
friends in the world in LA and just
everyday just millennial living you know
we have great cameos we have to say see
we have Cassie Scerbo we have so many
cameos that came and played with us so
I'm really excited about it we our next
stop is it's gonna be in San Francisco
and then we're gonna premiere it
everywhere for everyone to see oh really
yeah is there a timeline on when that'll
be
you can get all the information on the
fill series com is people just go they
can everything's on the the extra like
promo and the yeah that's so exciting
are you trying to kind of pivot more
into like the writing producing yeah
yeah I am I think for you know I've been
writing a lot in the last couple of
years just because I got tired of
waiting for someone to give you the
opportunity and you know it's really
inspirational to see friends who make
their own constant like Colleen and in
todrick Hall and yourself you know like
people who create their own content so I
it was like should I do something that
and Cooling want me to like you know you
should do a YouTube thing you know and
get on that and I was a kind of [ __ ] but
I can't devote myself to it because it's
like a weekly thing I was like I don't
know where I'm gonna be like in two
weeks and so I said I'm gonna write I'm
just gonna write you know what I know
and I've been writing stories and
pitching them and some things are up in
the air now
based on true life events and you know a
pretty interesting story like the whole
like being six years old and all that
yeah so I'm putting it all that down and
you know making stories out of it you
know so I'm doing that a lot now and I
love it I actually do because you're not
the mercy of someone else telling you
you're good enough mm-hmm you know it's
hard for like a character actor you know
I'm a character actor and I'm a person
of size and I'm Mexican you know and all
these things and those were seeing when
I first started going to your earlier
question as strikes against you right
you know so people were like well you're
already short and you're already fat and
you already this so those are strikes
they're against you and so you were
trying to like hey why not me you know
why not and then you have to show them
why not it's like look I could play this
because it would be a story like this
and then you can see me as why not am I
the heartthrob right now I'm at the love
interest you know I'm just recently
started doing like plus-size modeling
you know it sounded like hey you should
do it Oh your Instagram is on fire are
amazing weren't you just like in Utah or
something yeah yeah yeah I was a
beautiful like crazy yes so beautiful so
yes I thought that way if you were to
ask me maybe even ten years ago I would
have been like oh I think you got the
wrong / to me yeah yeah then I start
realizing why the [ __ ] not you know why
not me because you limit yourself
because you're told to limit yourself
yeah and so I got tired of it I'm like
I'm not let me myself anymore for
anybody yeah so I just started being me
bu who do you get messages now from
people that are thankful for you putting
yourself out there and like create ain't
paving your own way yeah I get messages
all the time let's people you know even
when they did the first series and I
play Alistar know which Alistar was like
the first the character at the end of
season one was gonna cross over
questioning if he was trans and going
m2f and so that was the first time that
was a challenge room because I'm not you
know but it was about to go in that
direction so the last episode we see
that and he was queer you know and we
established early on the season and I
just had all these like messages from
kids middle America like you know
they're like in Ojai or whatever like
thank you so much one of them was really
touching it was just like I was gonna
kill myself you know and I was like wow
and it's like but I saw that someone
like use on TV and playing someone like
that character and I relate to that
character so much I was like see what we
do is important yeah
so representation matters you know so it
that was the moment when I realized I
was like yes this is totally matter so I
still get messages like how do you do it
where do you like shop for cute clothes
you know open like a store for like you
know fabulous and plus size you know get
your full entrepreneurial stuff right
going yeah because you were always
asking that it's like yeah it's like
they make it hard for people of size to
like dress nice you know here's a potato
sack it's like you're wear that you know
make a fashion make it work it's like
I'll make it work do you have any
notable auditions that were really
horrible for you I always try to be
prepared like I always feel like if I go
to audition my mentality is I want a
obviously book it right sure but my my
goal is to book the room oh yeah yeah so
when I go into an audition
my audition better blow you away it
doesn't matter I could go in for the
wrong part completely wrong gender wrong
rate like anything doesn't matter I need
to blow you away
yeah and I've gone to ditions where I
knew the part wasn't right equipment for
the internship was important that I knew
was not right for me yeah but I was like
I feel like I can make it my own feel
and I got to shine got to meet the
director and we both knew that was like
this not where it was written down right
what you are does not wasn't you know
right and I just did my best and I did
my version of it I was like this is what
I'm doing you know this is what I'm
gonna do and I'm gonna do it well and
she was laughing on the floor and then
two weeks later I got a call
he wrote a part in the film for me wow
that's awesome
I booked that role really yeah I've
always said I'm not above anything like
after that it was an audition for a
Nickelodeon show that my age was like
it's two lines and it's a one-day guest
star let's pass and I was like no let me
see what time about the character oh
they're at a funeral why at the funeral
because he's a cousin so he's family
he's like yeah well family never goes
away smart and then it's like you want
to do it's two lines I was like okay I
go to do two lines my audition I booked
it within two weeks after shooting that
episode the I met the writers and
everyone they loved me they wrote a
whole episode for me Wow I record on
that show for four seasons
Wow so that mean that I think is just
great general advice for everyone I'm
taking like a seed of something your
seeds yeah see how much it can grow for
you absolutely I would say there's no
harm in playing this you know yeah
there's like other it sprouts and
something comes out of it or it's
something you planted that you leave
alone and you water it once in a while
whatever but if nothing comes from it
that's okay because you have the whole
garden that's so cool no I think that's
so fun and very inspiring what's
something like what do you do when you
get home from a long day on set or like
how do you unwind i watch reality TV
what do you yeah I literally caught up
with the last two episodes for Beverly
Hills yeah this morning yeah and I've
met like Kyle and Lisa have you I have
at a party and stuff enough and I just
know they're fighting I'm just like oh
so that's the one that I kind of go to
the housewives are all across the board
New York
Lanta yeah all them just sick obsessed
and that's what I kind of been doing and
people are what do you do for fun I
literally get in pajamas and like that's
okay we have the same hobbies out in my
mind yeah it's like mostly I go out it
feels like it's work yes I can I go out
as how there's a cool party that's work
yes socializing networking whatever but
when I stay home I'm just like would
there be any reality TV show that you
would go on yeah like um seeing Nicole's
show the nail dead oh yes yes yes
that shows Sophia I would go on that
because I think it's like I can't help
but like when I'm watching it I
generally like do commentary and yeah
Felicia was just on it so she said I got
your next you should do it and I was
like you know what maybe I will you can
see that happening I should do that too
do okay what would you title your memoir
hmm
a good title my memoir Memoirs of a
Geisha - the shot oh that's great
write it down okay let's say you got
invited to the Met Gala this last
go-round and the theme being camp
what would you dress up as I mean I
would just go full camp you know I was
surprised of how like some people were
yeah very like I'm a little disappointed
yeah it was like a little under what
like you know what are you doing what
are you doing there yeah camera off of
them 33 Credit Karma three go to camera
three see you've gotta count they're
like I feel like I'm dirty because it
just felt like people some people just
didn't put effort into it you know yeah
and as your the [ __ ] mikela the
best theme ever I was yeah I really
liked Katy Perry's burger change in the
bathroom yes I saw the video of her so
weird to see JLo in a public Randall it
was the most flattering like she just
comes out of this like in the door like
did not wash your hands she walks right
back if I was watching Katy Perry like
frantically scoop on this like foam
burger at the smart thing she was like
bye yeah that was a serial killer but I
did appreciate the camp that Katy Perry
brought I mean I think I've gone kind of
change anticipated her that's like her
normal aesthetic anyway yeah I think she
nailed it because it was ever met gala
that was up rally like yeah that was it
so just killed it and had costume change
I appreciate a good costume change day a
Gaga came in hot yeah I loved it she's
coming in hot
is there anyone in Hollywood you haven't
met yet that's like you would have a
freakout moment yes I think if I ever
ended up meeting or even working with
both of these ladies with Kate Winslet
Meryl Streep oh you imagine that'd be
insane that and whatever they want to
play like you know sisters our daughter
mother dynamic duo and I'm The Paperboy
yes hey I [ __ ] it up I can't even do
it
I can't even act out and make-believe
scenario right now talking about where's
auditions that was it I would love to
see that movie whatever it is even if
it's just a scene yeah I would love yeah
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back we have a bunch of
Twitter and Instagram questions for you
so we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
- TV brought to you by a Bud Light
shilada are you craving flavor and
refreshment this summer pick up one of
the three flavors of Bud Light colada
original extra lime and the newest
member of their family mango it's the
perfect drink for having a brunch on the
beach or just hanging out with friends
in the Sun the original gelato brings
you the crisp refreshing taste of Bud
Light with the rich signature taste of
Clamato tomato cocktail this distinctive
blend delivers a flavor that truly
refreshes and the chill a de extra lime
delivers a citrusy spin on the classic
chill out of flavor and the chill out of
mango brings a tropical touch to the
summertime favored to best enjoy at
relati gently rotate the chilled can
once before pouring then pour over ice
and garnish with a slice of lime some
celery or some mango salt the rim of
your glass or add a dash of hot sauce or
even more of a kick pick up a Bud Light
colada today and learn more at Bud Light
calm but light colada flavor that
refreshes so okay before we get into
these internet questions I'm gonna ask
you the two questions every single guest
that is on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at throw cold
spaghetti yet yes for fun or look as I
hate them you're it's up to you if I
hate them Hitler okay and then if I love
them
Lucille Ball oh that would be perfect
she might have fun with it no she make
it a full scene yeah okay the other
question is - tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine is college jogging front
lawn mine is college late rehearsal I
think that you had an immediate response
some people are like I've never okay
let's get into these questions someone
snow who are some of the comedians you
grew up idolizing
or got inspired by ooh that's a good one
well like again I didn't see a lot of
people who look like me on TV so for me
you know the closest thing would be like
George Lopez like growing up and then
later on like fluffy was really funny to
watch the comedian but early like rihwan
said watch as a kid would be like John
Candy um yeah that was good one
Bill Murray like in ghostbusters John
dan Aykroyd oh yeah yeah that kind of
vibe my early on like inspirations were
they were all white male you know
because there's no one to look like me
so I was looking for them I was really
looking for them and it wasn't till
later that I started seeing some so that
was my foundation and then it led to
like yeah you know yeah and I could
appreciate the craft from from anyone
who's an actor from any background you
know yeah yeah yeah that's super cool
know someone to know what special
vampire skill would you like to have
flying oh yeah yeah that's I love the
idea that you can fly like that's so
cool that was my favorite thing to shoot
a lot of people wanted to know what
what's it like to work around a voice as
amazing as Matt berries oh man his voice
like next yeah he just makes everything
funny you know his voice is so cool he
doesn't just say it much because he's so
funny you know yeah yeah he just said
what was your first impression of
everyone on set you know when I met
everyone again we had we didn't do like
a table read or a chemistry or anything
and they just flew from London oh wow
and I was literally the only American
there when we first met and then Mark is
also the in the series but we had to
just shot together so mark and I are
different Americans and we had no scenes
together my scenes were with all the
vampires with all the blood sucking
vampires rapper but it was just weird
because you know it's British humor too
so like Natasha hilarious and they don't
have accents and for me was the accent
getting like I'm not used to like such
British accents yeah I think they would
say something or it's a phrase or like
you know and I was like what does that
mean it means like you know like
whatever any description was and I
that's what took me a second but the
first thing that I thought of when I met
that was
I hope we just all get along so that one
did so it worked out that's awesome okay
someone wants to know who was your
favorite teacher um growing up my
favorite teacher probably mr. Miller in
third grade because I would sing I was
that annoying kid so after like you know
going to some improv classes I got a lot
of confidence uh-huh anything we sing a
Pledge of Allegiance and I be over the
top and he'd be like you you do that and
like you really encourage great teacher
be like that's enough you know and he
really did and he encouraged me and he
told my mom where I could like sign up
for stuff and like host things like
roadie like it was weird like he really
kind of became like a junior manager
sounds like he's managing it I'm never
gonna push away like your son has a gift
he wants to do this let him do it you
know yeah and he really did and I
remember being so thankful that my house
graduation I was like I wonder what mr.
Miller's doing and I try to look him up
and I was like I should've went to my
graduation because I felt so
accomplished is graduating high school
because I really could have gone the
other direction I was so like you know I
was a lot of kid in class and I would
have failed on my classes you know if I
didn't have any kind of structure given
to me because you know of theater yeah
and so I called him up and invited him
to micro he drove all the way down from
Xperia where that's where I went to
school in third grade and he drove all
the way down and came to my graduation
oh that's so sweet
yeah well he's a big fan of the podcast
so he's listening okay this message hey
someone's know what's been your worst
acting job ooh my worst acting job like
worst acting cuz it was my my worse
acting or was it because experience
probably was I would assume like it's
the experience of it that's okay cuz
you'll never see it he was looking my
IMDB credits and you probably figure you
know yeah but some things you shoot and
they never come out and thank God
someone's know what's your favorite
pick-me-up dance song ooh
I think anything Britney just like
Britney toxic comes out do you follow
her on social media yeah yeah yeah and
I've been following I'm a little
concerned yeah
I don't like that fact that she has to
make a video saying for those who do you
think this is any pest yeah it is me and
then she keeps looking off to the camera
and I was like well who is there who is
with you right now doing a fashion yeah
and it's clearly not on a tripod who is
holding this camera it's like if you
think that's not me it's definitely me I
am holding a selfie right now you're not
holding that bread like bread who is
there wink twice is there anyone else
that you like are obsessed with on
social media on social media
no not like obsessed I like I like to
scroll through everything but not like
obsessed do you have a favorite platform
that you prefer I think IG yeah yeah I
think just because it's easier you can
post everything at once
Twitter I was doing for a while but then
you don't get like the instant
gratification of watching someone's way
of life I am obsessed with somebody but
I won't even say the name because I just
watched it because it's so hilarious
like they touch up everything like their
photos are so touched
oh yeah and it's like but the goal is
always like living my best life is
healthy and it's like thighs shrunken
and shrunken you could just tell they've
like remodel either body I was like why
are you saying that like that's not even
what you're doing you know and the
shadow of them in the back is like the
real different not you know that's I
love seeing like real housewives and
people do that to their photos like
wasn't there that thing Lindsay Lohan
did it and like the like wall or
something or a staircase tiger it was
like wavy someone oh do you do stand-up
anywhere I just said that sometimes yeah
I used to do stand-up at the Ice House
on Pasadena ok and different places in
LA - but I rarely do I do it when
somebody calls like hey we're a spot you
wanna do it I was like yeah I don't like
to like plan like my shows coming up in
three months you know right not yet
anyways just because I've been writing
yes but I show you back to it so maybe I
will
maybe yeah some of us know what fun
would you like to have ooh like anybody
is familiar I think so yeah
I don't know I think Zac Efron has a
good work ethic so like I'm just like
that from would probably like you know
whatever you need yeah I mean I think
you'd be a very I think he's work ethic
is really well his body and like it and
his projects and favorite thing about
doing haters back off my favorite thing
was working with Colleen just like we
don't just see each other as much as we
would want and so if it's work it's
still fun you know so yes each other
yeah
that's great okay last question someone
says Harvey you simply emulate Beauty
teach me your ways oh that's so that's
really nice thank you that's C just do
you and if you inspire someone that's
all you can ask for that's awesome this
has been so fun thank you for making
time for that thanks for having me I
miss it before we go completely every
guest that makes time for our little
thing here gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us to them personalized
that's a you choice vampires are real
and thank the heavens
Ruth cater Ginsburg is one she's not
going anywhere
I'll be the coolest if she if she well
she talked about like a great familiar
yeah RBG yeah incredible but she's more
powerful as a vampire yeah okay where
can people find what you're up to
if they don't know yeah you can follow
me on Twitter and on Instagram at Harvey
Guillen that's my full name at Harvey
Guillen perfect and anything other than
season two coming up we're doing some
stuff in the background I'm working on
some projects right now Carrie talked
about it
but some cool stuff I'm gonna be
shooting this summer film so they're
gonna look out for that awesome and the
filth and the help go to the fill series
calm and you can get all your
information there we have a great cast
and if you are in San Francisco later in
June come up with a Film Festival up
there and we'll say hi awesome well
thank you again so much this has been
really fun guys we'll see you next time
another episode of not too deep good bye
beiiy 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep whatever
struggles are facing from depression and
anxiety to trauma and grief better help
and connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapists and anything you share it's
completely confidential and festive yet
it's truly an affordable option not too
deep with grace Helbig listeners get 10%
off your first month with a discount
code grace so why not get started go to
better help calm slash grace and fill
out a questionnaire to get matched with
a counselor that you'll love today not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]